[Music]
thank you
hello once again and welcome to I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program where we get to answer your
questions from the word of God and we
have a great time doing so I'm in the
company of two distinguished gentlemen I
like to call them distinguished because
It embarrasses them because it is so
very true a Pastor Stephen Bohr our
founder and principal speaker here at
Secrets unsealed and some TV pastors
always it is a pleasure having you here
this is one of my favorite Endeavors at
Secrets unsealed is answering questions
on this program praise the Lord you
spend an awful lot of time on the road
so when we get to have you here we like
to work you to death uh as it were
because you're gone so much you have
spoken literally
and the the newest member of our tribe
someone we're getting to know and love
very much Pastor amen Salazar Pastor
again good to have you here thank you
for having me here it was always a
pleasure also to be here and to join and
support the team and the ministry here
of course praise the lord we we we find
it uh maybe not artists not not the way
to say it but uh so interesting how when
we act we study the the questions uh
separately but when we come together so
many times we have the same text and our
minds move in the same way and that's
because we are dare I say theologically
conservative and that in some places
that's a dirty word it is not here amen
um uh because we like to take the Bible
for what the Bible has to say not to add
to it not to embellish it certainly not
to take away from it but try to stay as
close we can to the word of God and that
makes one conservative in today's world
that's right but that is a badge we wear
proudly uh we make you this promise as
we always do that if an answer can be
found to your question from the word of
God we will find it if it can be found
and give it to you from the word of God
uh not our own opinion uh we make you
that promise so if you'd like to get in
on the fun if you have a question that
you'd like us to answer to wrestle with
we ask you to write us at TV at
sumtv.org that's TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we will by the grace of
God get to your question as soon as we
possibly can the questions come in Daily
uh and so the stack is rather impressive
uh we're working our way through it and
uh sometimes we get to one question
sometimes two sometimes three per show
it all depends on the the complexities
of the question but we want to do do
difference if you take the time to write
us we want to take the time to answer
and to answer it as thoroughly as
possible and so we want to launch out
this very day Pastor if you would uh ask
the Lord's blessing upon our studies
today certainly Father in heaven we
realize and recognize that our wisdom
and knowledge is so limited good we know
just enough to get from point A to point
B from this Earth To Heaven
we ask that as we look at these
questions today
that you will bless us you will give us
wisdom to answer them correctly
we appreciate so many people that send
us questions that are wondering about
certain things in your word and we just
ask that you will be with us Enlighten
our minds and bless those who are
watching this program amen and above all
we ask that your name will be honored
and glorified in this program today we
pray in Jesus name amen amen amen amen
Pastor Bohr I'm going to ask you to read
this question it comes to us from Puerto
Rico from Ariel Josue Aponte Figueroa
and you may have to concise and chop it
a little bit and triage a little bit as
you go through it but uh uh take a look
at this one and then we'll try to work
our way through it you know before I do
let me say that I Marvel at your
pronunciation of the Spanish language
we've been trying to encourage CA to do
Spanish programming with us but we
haven't been able to convince him yet
but maybe if if we twist his arm to the
breaking point we might be able to
he will okay this is a rather long
question
um and I'll go through it quickly hello
once again by the way I'm getting
current with I'd like to know programs
since I didn't watch it for some time
I like watching every program that's why
I'm making some questions about answers
you gave to questions in programs some
time ago may God keep blessing you and
the people who look for answers in this
program so he's back basically asking a
question about one of our answers
in one program you were answering a
question about the Christmas tree and if
it was was or not an idolatrous practice
to hang offerings on it as E.G white
encouraged to encourage us to do since
God would be well pleased you said Ellen
White said you can make Christmas
whatever you want to make it and also
the motive determines the value of the
ACT according to the spirit of Prophecy
now come the questions
doesn't that suggest that doing
something wrong but with good in
quotation marks motive motives is okay
when in fact it is wrong for example can
we make Halloween whatever we want to
make it what's the difference between
all the holidays Christmas Halloween
Easter Saint Valentine St Patrick's Etc
if ultimately we can observe them as
long as our motives are good or can we
kill someone as long as our motives are
good
doesn't seem like it according to John
16 verses 2 and 3 and other examples in
the Bible
or even can we worship some object as
long as we have it as just a symbol of
the true God
doesn't seem like it according to Exodus
32 and Daniel 3 and other examples in
the Bible or can we disobey God but
apparently have good reasons to do so
doesn't seem like it according to First
Samuel 15 22 and 23 and a lot of other
examples in the Bible I have observed
that the Bible teaches that doing
something bad with good motives is as
wrong as doing something good with bad
motives am I mistaken with this correct
and enlighten me if I am please I love
the truth I appreciate the sincerity
with which this person asks the question
I think it's a good question it is a
good question
um the first thing I say in China to to
bite off he's got a lot here
some of the examples he gives
are examples that fly in the face of a
direct command from God
if you have a Commandment that says Thou
shalt not kill there's no way you can
sanitize that because of a good motives
so uh it doesn't really fit here as far
as an example of Christmas when you have
a a thus saith the Lord then it is thus
saith the Lord and nothing else so
there's no way to to to to to to to
clean that up to sanitize that so
um I've got to take out all of those
things that did with killing and those
other kinds of things because we've got
a clear directive from God as to how to
proceed in that in that matter
um let me stop there and let you guys
pick it up
I I would like to probably mention that
he's in a way answering his own question
when he states that
he actually read or heard the program
and so that you answer from Super
prophecy specifically about the
Christmas tree being according to the
our prophet and Andrew White mentioning
that it will be well pleased to the Lord
to have a Christmas tree on every church
and I believe that by his stating that
and we can actually read that also quote
from Spirit prophecy where clearly she
mentions that aspect I think it's he's
kind of creating a problem in his own
mind if you will you know uh because
we're not putting or the program has
never tried to make a assumption that we
think all holidays are acceptable or or
level all the uh things that go along
with those holidays are good we're not
stating that or making that assumption
as a matter of fact we don't also
believe that Christmas trees are that
are allowed are to be worshiped so
there's nothing you know they're they're
not together you know having a Christmas
tree does not mean that we're putting an
item in a church to be worshiped that or
or some sort of given some sort of uh
Holiness to it and it's just a symbol
that is used to bring people together to
give to the Lord to be able to uh be
thankful for what he has given them
throughout the whole year and that was
the emphasis to give offerings of thanks
to the Lord and in that sense is what
really we're trying to stick to just
what the spirit Prophet says nothing
else nothing more and I think that's
sort of what you have to be careful not
to assume that we're encouraging
somebody to go along with some
Valentines or any other things you know
life since day or St Patrick's Day
whatever he mentioned one of the issues
that that this
particular question or series of
questions brings up
uh is this
is the practice explicitly forbidden in
scriptures yes that's the that's the big
issue and uh you know you take for
example uh one of the things that he
mentions here can we worship some object
as long as we have it as just a symbol
of the true God the Bible explicitly
forbids that yes because it says in
Exodus chapter 20 you shall not make for
yourselves a carved image any likeness
of anything that is in heaven above or
that is in the earth beneath or that is
in the water under the Earth You shall
not bow down to them nor serve them that
is explicitly forbidden in the Bible so
uh you know if something is not
explicitly forbidden in the Bible then
we apply the principle yes yes
um very well balanced so when we look at
things like Halloween a celebration of
of death and dead based on an erroneous
understanding of the state of the dead
that's that that's forbidden that's not
even of course you can't put that in the
same category as Christmas Saint
Patrick's Day Saint Valentine's Day well
the moment you say saint
yeah you know it's gone it's just it's
just not in this same category right
he mentioned God would be well pleased
so
um with with all respect his premise is
is is wrong he's starting from the wrong
premise that we're taking a day and
trying to sanitize it and make it
acceptable to God we've already been
given the understanding that it is
acceptable to God if celebrated this
particular way so that divorces it from
Valentine's Day and Easter and Halloween
and all these other kinds of days uh
it's in a different category and we
don't bring the tree in for purposes of
worship or adoration we bring it in as a
a focal point to do good things for
those who we're trying to serve at this
time of year right so he's starting from
the wrong premise another example of a
passage that he mentions uh and let me
just go back here or can we disobey God
by apparently having good reasons to do
so doesn't seem like it occur according
to First Samuel 15 22-23 so let's take a
look at that but we have to go a little
bit broader in our perspective uh go
back to verse 19.
of first Samuel 15. and it's dealing
with the destruction of the amalekites
so it says why then did you not obey the
voice of the Lord why did you swoop down
on the spoil and do evil in the sight of
the Lord because God had said don't take
anything that is there verse 20 and Saul
said to Samuel but I have obeyed the
voice of the Lord and gone on the
mission on which the Lord sent me and
brought back a gag king of amalek I have
utterly destroyed the amalekites but the
people took of the plunder now he's
passing the buck sheep and oxen the best
of the things which should have been
utterly destroyed to sacrifice to the
Lord your God and gilian those we took
all these things to offer them as a
sacrifice to the Lord and then God's
response is the key
through Samuel so Samuel said has the
Lord has great Delight in burnt
offerings and sacrifices as in obeying
the voice of the Lord behold to obey is
better than sacrifice and to heed than
the fat of Rams for Rebellion
he said we're dealing here with sinning
against known light right God does not
say you cannot cannot have a Christmas
tree now if we were bowing and
worshiping the Christmas tree that would
be a different story so the the bottom
line is that uh Samuel I mean Saul
seemed to have good and good intentions
good motives but he had clear light that
he wasn't supposed to do that precisely
precisely when you go against the clear
thus saith the Lord the spoken word of
God that's error that sin that that does
not exist with Christmas and the
Christmas tree good intentions that's
not you know make something uh good you
know if he's a sin is a sin and we are
definitely not suggesting by any means
that their action or the motives
justifies the action you know we are to
be transparent and as we follow the lord
All Things Must line up with what God
wants us to do how we are to live and
definitely act according to that even if
you know
um not might not be the most popular
thing to do uh with that in mind also
remember that we are not to just
look good in doing something but
actually doing it for the right reason
so there has to be those two elements
you know we believe that
another biblical example of this is some
people try to justify Lying by what
Rahab did you know they say well she had
good intention she lied and she saved
the spies but the interesting thing is
if you read carefully the passages that
speak about this both in the Old
Testament and the book of Hebrews it
never says that God approved of her line
it says that you know she was hospitable
and she accepted them absolutely and she
sent them out another way but never does
God say that it was okay for her to lie
right so uh so we need to be sure that
whatever God strictly forbids
uh we cannot disobey with good
intentions but what God does not
strictly forbid then there is uh there's
wiggle room as long as it does not
violate other biblical principles you're
here here's what I appreciate about
appreciate about brother Figueroa
um he says correct and enlighten me
uh please I love truth amen that that's
the right way to approach the word of
God absolutely with the love of Truth
and with an understanding to accept and
follow that which we know to to be right
so you present truth we leave it in the
the hands and the Heart of the hearer
and if their heart is right God will
lead them anyway you know and I greatly
appreciate uh the fact that he sends us
a question based on one of our answers
and I would encourage anyone who watches
this program if we provide an answer
that you find an issue with uh please
send us uh you know another question or
send us a rebuttal so that we can do
research because we are not infallible
on this program you know all of you have
to do what the Apostle Paul said about
the bereans you know check it out you
see uh that what we're saying is in
harmony with the word of God you know we
are fallible human beings and so you
need to check out everything that we we
say that's right our safety lies on
following what the word of God says and
it's for prophecy
it also gives us light into stepping
aside from that it's dangerous and
that's where we have to be careful
because sometimes people can come with
uh you know great even preachers can can
bring certain topics that can confuse uh
you know the audience into thinking that
doing something wrong and it's not
really biblically found or based in its
purpose either so you have to be very
careful I think that we need to really
rely more on the word of God is prayer
prophecy than than what somebody else
might say amen amen amen you can be
sincere and sincerely wrong I remember
the the early fathers of of the
Adventist Church preached shut door you
know no one else can be saved the time
has passed they're preaching and people
are coming to the Lord so that we've got
to reevaluate because people are coming
it's the door is shut how come these new
people are coming to the Lord so they
have to re-evalue their theological
premise and they realize the door was
not shut uh so you change you grow and
as you find new information you you
accept and follow that new information
thank you very much uh coming into us
from Puerto Rico we appreciate it 23
years old young fella yeah yes that's
almost 24.
praise the Lord praise the Lord I don't
know if he's looking forward to that
all right I'll have the next question
I'll ask and you gentleman will answer
uh well we'll answer but uh let's see
from Michael this question comes from
Michael and he's a question about the
crucifixion very interesting question he
says why did Satan crucify Christ and
allow Christ to shed the covering blood
and complete the Plan of Salvation
wouldn't Satan have done more harm not
allowing Christ to die for our sins so
there's two questions here and very very
good questions
what it takes
John chapter 18 verse 37 for this reason
came I enter the world Satan was not in
control of the life and death of Christ
Christ came to shed his blood that was a
plan designed in heaven before the
foundation of the world so
um we cannot act as though Satan was in
charge here he was not Satan wasn't the
the orchestrator of this this was a
divine plan uh that was worked out long
before Satan uh instigated that crowd to
call for Christ's death on Calvary you
know Satan tried to kill Christ several
times during his ministry yes you know
he he influenced a crowd to push Jesus
over a cliff that's right and uh when
the storm arose on the lake it was his
intention to drown him yes and several
times during his ministry Satan tried to
incite the crowd to Stone Christ so the
devil did want to kill Christ yes
however
uh when Jesus died on the cross
it was not Satan who was killing him
because the Bible tells us that Jesus
once for all
offered himself
he was the victim and he was the priest
he officiated his own sacrifice in other
words Satan did not take his life Jesus
said I lay down my life that I may take
it up again so you know the premise of
the question is why did Satan crucify
Christ well Satan did not crucify Christ
in fact what Satan wanted to do in the
closing hours of Christ's life was to
make his life so miserable that he
wouldn't die in fact in Gethsemane if
you read the chapter Gethsemane and
Desire of Ages Ellen White says he
tortured Jesus with with a thought that
if he went forward with this it would be
fruitless yes look at your own disciples
turned against you one of your disciples
betrayed you you know why are you going
forward with this
up to the point even when he was hanging
on the cross yet Satan enticed the the
those who are at the foot of the cross
to say oh he saved others come on come
on down from the cross so Satan did not
win Jesus to die what happened was that
he influenced the crowd and they had
such a frenzy that it backfired on here
he couldn't control the crowd anymore
that's a good point
and questionable you're you're you know
what you mentioned is very true and we
have to remember that
really there was no other Plan of
Salvation in this aspect uh you know the
omnipotent on omnip
uh omniscience without the words yeah
omniscience correct of God
could not Define another way it was only
one way for salvation to come to the
Fallen race Christ had to die and like
you said give his own life for us and uh
you know the enemy even pushed him to
the concept of the idea that if he was
to go ahead with it since Jesus was
determined he said you know if you
continue with this you will never
be accepted by the father again so
Christ by you know Faith the spirit says
you know he had to basically accept the
fact that even though he could not see
beyond the death you know he was willing
to sacrifice because it was the only way
possible for us to be saved so he gave
himself completely and that's why the
dead on the cross even though yes the
Roman soldiers were physically the ones
that knocked into the cross and even
though the multitudes were asking him to
be crucified uh and Satan instigated
them like you mentioned honestly it was
the sin you know what made him die in
the cross for us pain our penalty or or
price and therefore uh he needed to do
that to complete the plan salvation and
it had to be done so there was you know
Satan as he asks would Satan have done
more harm not allowing Christ to die for
our sins uh he would have done actually
more more harm in making Christ's
attempt I mean or fall into temptation
to say giving up on this plan Lord this
is too much for me or or falling to sin
so that's really what it comes down to
it you know sometimes question the
question comes up
um what would have happened if the Jews
had accepted Christ how would he have
died
and my answer is that's not the way it
happened
I think it was Martin Luther who said
somebody asked him what was God doing
before he created the world Martin
Luther said he was preparing hell for
those who asked foolish questions
[Laughter]
Luther had a way of of saying things
which was quite abrasive sometimes yeah
of course but you know the bottom line
is did God the Father know
and everything that was going to happen
during the ministry of Christ from
eternity past of course he did so uh you
know God maneuvered being that he knew
the choices that everyone was going to
make yeah he maneuvered things so that
Jesus would sacrifice his life uh not as
the ideal
but as the real as it was going to
happen yeah and by the way
um I have this interesting statement
that I was sharing you know when we were
talking before this program where uh you
know you have for example the movie that
was done by Mel Gibson The Passion of
the Christ you know the whole emphasis
of the movie is on the beating and the
suffering of Christ the torture of
Christ you know being whipped and
everything and bleeding but you know he
had this interesting statement Ellen
White wrote in Bible training school
September 1 1915
In The Garden of Gethsemane Christ
suffered in man's Stead
so it's not the death of Christ that
stands only in our stead it says
suffering and Gethsemane yes and the
human nature of the Son of God staggered
under the terrible horror of the guilt
of sin until from his pale and quivering
lips was forced the agonizing cry oh my
father if it be possible let this cup
pass from me but if there be no other
way by which the salvation of man may be
accomplished then not as I will but as
thou Wilt now here comes a key portion
human nature would then and there have
died
under the horror of the sense of sin had
not an angel from heaven strengthened
him to Bear the agony it wasn't the
physical beating that led to the death
of Christ he would have died in the
garden before anyone put a finger on him
he was offering himself that's why he's
crying out to the father if it's
possible that this cup of Wrath uh you
know passed from me Let It Be So
nevertheless not my will be done but
your will so the bottom line is that
Satan did not crucify Christ yes yes you
know I I had written here just the word
psychological the the fact that a lot of
what Satan put on Christ was
psychological warfare we understand that
he he was he was scarcely
in the presence of the physical because
of the weight of sin and dealing with
that so a lot of you know he knew how
how abhorrent sin was to his father so
Satan say you know you you're taking all
the sin he's never going to take you
back yeah you know uh that that kind of
thing so he's he's carrying all this
weight of of sin
um and if Satan could have gotten him to
doubt his father or doubt his mission in
any aspect he still would ever want so
uh it was not only the death it was the
fact that Christ was faithful to the
point of death amen yeah so it's it's a
complex thing and Satan was not in
charge absolutely and Satan wanted to
destroy Christ as by Sir board mentioned
earlier you know several times he said
CA you've mentioned six times that you
can remember he was born you know yeah
when he was a little kid you know wanted
to destroy him had he destroyed him
before the Fulfillment of time before he
was ready to give up his life
voluntarily he would have succeeded in
getting rid of the Plan of Salvation
ahead of time but Christ as we've seen
the Lord you know made sure that it was
not through the intention of Satan but
through his son giving on his own life
for us amen he became possible amen
already well our time has quickly
slipped into eternity allowed me in
closing to wish you Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
will see you again soon good night God
bless
[Music]
thank you